well what do you like to watch around
7:00 or 7:30 at night little program
called Milly was all of 12 years old
then she's grown up fast in the last
three years Millie's TV Guardian also
took our trip down memory lane so you
see the passage of time with her I was
like really when we were just doing a
show that we didn't know that anyone
would like well they did and now with
season three of the supernatural series
expect that budding romance we've
followed between millionth in to go a
little bit further watching this
relationship play out is so much fun
yeah we just have fun with it I think it
was with somebody else I wouldn't feel
as yeah I think because we'd known each
other since we were like you know I mean
they're just kissing right speaking of
growing up in front of us 47 year old
Winona Ryder has done just that she was
just 17 when we first met her she had
two Oscar nominations before she was 25
but then her career slowed down until
stranger things call there is no
question that it has completely changed
my life
I feel very indebted to them and just
grateful feel so lucky I'm Robin new to
the series is my AHA she's grown up in
the spotlight also she's the daughter of
uma Thurman and Ethan Hawke did you get
any advice from your parents before you
stepped into this big franchise there's
not one nugget it's like a lifetime of
nuggets and of having been brought up
and raised and taken care of to try to
be a good person
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]